[Music]
i'm worries harris and over the next 30
days you'll go from admiring
centerpieces to creating your own
masterpieces
in this class i'm going to teach you
what to think about when purchasing
flowers and how to consider color
texture and dimension in your designs
during this course you are going to make
a classic arrangement a table
arrangement wreaths bouquets and even
your own signature arrangement boom how
about that
this step-by-step process is designed to
help you build your confidence with your
flower arranging skills as a florist
i've worked with rashida jones i was a
sunni maya rudolph and i'm really good
at what i do
or at least that's what beyonce says
during our time together i'll be giving
you some tips you want to guide that
stem through the middle and then you
want to pull it from the bottom a lot of
encouragement cause i got you and some
really helpful assignments i'm gonna
make sure that you have everything you
need to unlock your creative voice
and the community you're learning with
is here to help
they're going to send you all the love
and all the support you need to bring
your signature style to life
keep pushing you got this
so go out explore find new things let's
have some fun
i'm maurice harris and this is
masterclass
[Music]
you